what do i do first maybe I'll rescue a
damsel in distress or be a bounty hunter
right this way sir okay try not to be
too J I'm dressed up in the coolest
Western hero of all time Marty McFly
that was a clip from the TV comedy Robot
Chicken now in its tenth season the show
is TV's longest-running stop-motion
animated series on the air and just this
month the show won its sixth Emmy for
Outstanding short form animated program
stupid buddy Studios produces Robot
Chicken and a number of other shows
including a superhero theme program
that's attracting some of Hollywood's
biggest names Jaime wax paid the studio
a visit what was the initial approach
that they took to you to say would you
want to be in a big way a part of this
show I thought well this is interesting
I'd like to see if I have any ability in
that arena and what I realized it's that
it's it really isn't any different than
doing then considering my movie
television or stage work we have to move
our product in bulk wholesale Emmy
Golden Globe and Tony award-winning
actor Bryan Cranston is in the enviable
position of being able to choose the
projects he lends his name and talents
to are you Moreland Stephens the
stop-motion animated series super
mansion is doorbell I said as long as we
can really get into the character
motivations and allow our audiences to
to be behind these characters and root
for them then I'm excited about it it
kind of wants to see a leprechaun it's
funny and it's out there
bizarre oh my god but yet it still feeds
that beast of the those super fans who
love fantasy the comic-con group that we
we love to embrace are you wearing
shorts that a problem it's about the
interpersonal relationships of
superheroes it's
not about the fights it's about stuff as
simple as shopping for pizza rolls and
whether you get the vegan brand or the
Totino's super mansion is just one of
four animated series stupid buddy
Studios is now producing it's the
brainchild of actor Seth Green his
friend Matthew Senreich John Harvey teen
and Eric towner their adventure began in
this Winnebago harvey teaming towners
first office it sort of started as an
animation Clubhouse where we were just
hanging out with friends you know making
projects that we were really excited
about so you had some serious meetings
in this Winnebago though there was some
high-level meetings just outside of the
house yeah I mean we'd be having you
know some super important phone calls
and the people on the other line had no
idea that we were inside of a Winnebago
and shirts off because it's so hot Seth
Green is the best known of the group
with a long list of acting credits
including the Austin Powers movie
franchise and he provides the voice of
Chris Griffin on the long-running
animated series Family Guy creating his
own series was something of an
unexpected project here I come bad guys
and boobs Robot Chicken was born out of
just wanting to make something and my
friend Matthew son rush and I said about
making what was just gonna be a
stop-motion short so this was this was
never meant to be this big I wouldn't
say that we set out to make a show that
would run for 10 seasons know that that
we weren't even wyatt life takes you in
strange places right maybe even more
unexpected Robot Chicken has won six
Emmy Award know quite a record for an
unconventional comedy that specializes
in off-the-wall pop-culture parodies
including Star Wars
yeah you did I thought it was Darth
Vader just some dude it was its these
incredible opportunities to play with
the most important pop culture of the
moment and make something that's silly
at the same time that it's very loving
of the source material the final product
may be silly but the production worth is
serious business everything is set up
just like it would be in a regular
studio for live-action movie making
it's just miniaturized it's
painstakingly slow but the result is so
good so slow it takes about a week to
animate just one minute of material in
this scene
Rex figures out that devised Oh has
stranded Debbie on the island for years
stupid buddy Studios has 225 employees
40 miniature sound stages a workshop
that handcrafts all the puppets and even
a wardrobe department that creates tiny
costumes with my new detail this has got
to be the dream job yeah I mean this is
what I love doing it for me it started
when when I was a kid it was it was
making movies and and really at a young
age that just fell in love with
animation it's the fact that you can
touch these things and they come to life
I'm picking up the action figures I had
as a child and making them come to life
with the imagination that I used to have
while telling stories as a kid I feel
like there's like heart and emotion all
of it like every step when it comes to
the puppets of the sets of the animation
there's an artist that's touching every
aspect of it they did they're here
because they love doing this work and I
think that's what kind of shines in the
animation that's one of the draws for
Cranston's working with a group of
grown-up kids still in touch with the
magic of their childhood there is a keen
sense of childlike behavior in all of
these people and and I don't mean that
derisive Lee I mean that like oh they're
still holding on to the sweetness to the
to the sense of wonder to the fantasy of
it all two superheroes in their minds
that they grew up with and I love being
around people who retain a sense of
childlike qualities it's it's refreshing
what's the dream for this company we
never actually dared to dream any of
this it's kind of just been a strange
unfolding of circumstance and then of a
willingness to go a little bit further
if we could continue to make shows if we
can continue to make movies if we can
continue to keep the lights on and keep
people employed that's a pretty I think
that's a pretty good goal for CBS this
morning Saturday Jaime wax Los Angeles I
love that stuff yeah adult kids well put
I just love the detail in the
craftsmanship of stop-motion animation
yeah Gumby and pokey yes back to those
right back to that